بابا وماما كانوا كانوا يعطوني مصروف و
لعبونا وكنا نلعب انا
وياهم
كانوا
يدرسونا وانا اشتقت لهم كتير يا ريتهم
معايا اسمي محمود محمد رياض
الحصري احنا اول رايحين نشتري بعدين
روحنا انقصف الدار
علينا بعدين
ايش
بعدين رحنا على الشفا وماما
استشهدات
وبابا ثلاث اخوات استشهدوا واحد اسم رزان
واحد اسم بيسان هذا اسمها جنان كانوا
يلعبونه كنا نروح مع بعض مع على المدرسه
اه ولو كان هنا انا ما حسيتش
بالوجع محمود عمره ثمان سنوات هو بيكون
ابن
بنتي محمود فاد كل عيلته اثناء قصف طيران
في شارع النفق محمود طلعوه من تحت الانقاض
كان يعني كله مكسر وكل لحمه وكل راسه مكسر
واخذوه على الشفاء انا لقيته بالشفاء يعني
عرفنا على الامه وعلى الجسس وعلى اخواته
بصعوبه يعني فيش جيت كله هذا كان متسمى
زياد جمال ياسين عمر 14 سنه تصوبت على
دحله البلديه في غزه كانت الكويت كطر
علينا زي المطر ترش علينا رصاص تصوبت في
بطني رجعت لابويا فاجا يحملني تصوب معي
وقعدنا يعني نروح يمين شمال نقعد نقف
نطخ
علينا المواطن جمال زياد ياسين وابني زياد
جمال ياسين صار طف علينا من طياره الكود
كابتر
الصغيره فالولد بعد عني ما يقارب س 8 متر
الطياره تخطه في اصابيع رجليه اصابيع
ايديه وتخطوا طلق في بطنه طلعت الامعاء في
الطلق هذا فزع علي يا ب رحت اجري الحقه ان
انقذه فيا دوب احمله تصوبت فوق اصبع ايدي
واخذنا جنب ساتر على جنب س هتصب في
ظهره بندور انا واخويا بعد ما انقصف ن
ظلينا مع بعض
واخويا بعيد عني بغزه وانا مشتاق
له مش عارف
عن اخوه احمد هلقيت في غزه مع ابني الثاني
برضه احمد متصاوب كانت كل الجلده تبعت
ايده طالعه للعظم الثاني والثاني بعاني
بيعملها على حاله لا ارادي ولحتى الان
الاولاد الاثنين مصدومين مش مستوعبين كل
اللي جر لهم كان عامل عمليه في الاندونيسي
وعمليه في ال مع مداني اجينا هان بدنا
ليله ثاني يوم عملوا له عمليه برضه وما
زال زياد بتوجع يعني لا بنام ليل ولا بنام
نهار اموره صعبه كثير واحنا مش عارف يعني
الشيء بسوق بسوق كثير اكثر من اللازم
الولد طول الليل بعي حتى لما بتذكر اهله
بتذكر اخوته بتذكر عماته الثنتين اللي
استشهدوا مع اولادهم كان مع اولادهم يلعب
كنا نروح عندهم ونلعب مع بعض يعني وكنا ن
كانت ايام حلوه يعني معهم كل ما
اذكرهم خلص
بصر